let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
happy happy happy hump day
thanks for joining us on let's talk to
tony michael's podcast
it's wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern you know what time
that is
it's time
to kick it off here and we have a
special guest for you today a special
guest interview for you today
heather gardner is gonna be here we're
gonna play trivia me and gabe play
trivia with heather we play game show
trivia as a matter of fact
a lot of fun a lot of fun we had a lot
of fun we pre-recorded our guest
episodes as you know here on the tony
michaels podcast so we have a great
interview with heather we have we have
a fantastic trivia game and then we have
a new segment
called one more thing at the very end so
stay tuned uh for that
to find out what one more thing is and
then you can get down in the comments
and tell us what you think
of the one more thing if we should keep
doing that with guest or not i know you
guys love the trivia so we're going to
keep doing the trivia
every time we have a guest on we like
playing trivia it's really fun today's
game um is really really fun so stay
tuned for that later on in the show
we're also going to talk about the
bonehead of the week me and gable talk
about the bonehead of the week today
so stay tuned for that we also have a
great uh great video that we found on
the internet
of the
the lawmakers tweets to to mark meadows
and some of the other fox news tweets
to mark meadows this is big news um
yeah
the news
is bigger than
than fox news itself because fox news
isn't news
we all knew this they all knew this [ __ ]
this wasn't a big [ __ ] surprise
that fox news isn't news [ __ ] duh
um
so we're gonna talk about that today in
the talk we'll bring gabe in and talk
about that we also have the [ __ ] list
today um and i think
if you guys watch the shitless roundup
today i did i don't know i did like 45
minutes on this cheesecake factory thing
these crazy ass anti-vaxxers um crying
and whining that they can't get a piece
of [ __ ] cheesecake from the
cheesecake factory like the cheesecake
factory is the only [ __ ] place that
makes cheesecake number one number two
you can make cheesecake at home you dumb
[ __ ]
like that's a thing
like you know the cheesecake factory
like i don't know if they're so [ __ ]
stupid that they're like that's the only
place that makes cheesecake because it's
called the cheesecake factory where else
are you gonna get [ __ ] cheesecake
besides the cheesecake factory
yeah cheesecake you can make it at home
at grocery store sell it walmart will
bring literally if you like you order it
at walmart
or like a retailer that is that makes
cheesecake they'll probably bring it to
you to your [ __ ] car
like they'll st they'll give it to you
it's your car you order it online with
your little [ __ ] appy app you know
the cell phone that you're recording the
stupid [ __ ] anti-facts video that you
think is good propaganda for you
horrible for you it makes you look dumb
it makes you look [ __ ] stupid that
same cell phone that you're recording on
you can order a cheesecake from a store
drive to the store and they'll bring it
out to you and then you can drive your
dumb ass home and eat your [ __ ]
cheesecake
oh anti-vaxxer cheese cake debacle
holy actual [ __ ]
these people these people are [ __ ]
dumb
so that was what the shitless roundup
was today mainly
uh patriot takes was
i had a whole thread of these videos of
these stupid anti-vaxxers thinking that
they're entitled to cheesecake they're
constitutionally entitled to cheesecake
anyway
[ __ ]
these people lost their way
this jfk crt voodoo [ __ ]
i also think they're they're
constitutionally titled the cheesecake
jeez that's [ __ ] christ
so i think i'll leave that one alone
even though i'm i don't know a couple
minutes on it here uh
i think i'll leave that topic alone
today on the [ __ ] list roundup i really
want to uh talk about these
the
these
seditious lawmakers and what that means
and these contempt charges for mark
meadows i think that's probably the most
important thing to be talking about
right now as far as
democracy is concerned there's a hell of
a lot of other stuff to talk about
uh with mansion and the the
big bird bill as we call it here the
education bill where kids get to start
at the age of three they start school at
the age of three and then they get to go
to school
two years after high school so you not
only get a high school degree you get an
associate's degree with public education
now that's what the big bird bill does
so uh joe mancha there's that important
thing there's a lot of important stuff
going on out there i mean speaking of
education the buying administration is
making some choices on education that
some people are liking some people are
not as far as the student loan relief
goes
and there's also kroger is changing some
of their code policies so there's a lot
of important [ __ ] going on
but as far as democracy is concerned you
know we are pro-democracy show we
promote democracy we want we want to
gather up as many pro-democracy people
as we can to send a message
of pro-democracy in our country to know
what is at stake to go [ __ ] vote
so we want to keep doing that here
and that so i want to talk about one of
the existential threats of our democracy
which is seditious lawmakers and we've
seen those texts so we're going to talk
about that today on the [ __ ] list and
again stay tuned stay tuned for the
entire two hours because we do two hours
now because heather gardner is going to
be on the host of occupy democrats
trivia show you can win a thousand bucks
by the way
if you go over there tonight they're
doing it
all week
occupy democrats is doing it all week
where you can win up to a thousand
dollars a thousand bucks that's a lot of
christmas money so you can go over there
check that out
but stay tuned for heather heather's
interview later on in the show today
but
stay with us right now we'll be right
back with the [ __ ] list
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part and blanket
specifically works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
january 6th and if you're one of the
other members of congress who also
helped with the attempted coup pardon
blanket will protect you too hard and
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
100 made in the usa don't delay and get
your part and blanket today for just
99.99
partying is not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast
paul gosar may need a pardon blanket
don't you think
uh the parodies the parodies are getting
real and real and realer and realer
aren't they you can't even make this
[ __ ] up anymore like literally you can't
you can't even make something up
it's impossible to make something up to
make fun and satire these [ __ ] idiots
because they are the satire themselves
it's absolutely incredible we've seen
this week with not not only the the text
from lawmakers because we're going to
talk about that here
but um the the the the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] text from the fox news host
which is absolutely [ __ ] bonkers
that that that that is that is a thing
that happened think about it can you
imagine can you imagine just just
just close your eyes for me just one
second
before we get to the [ __ ] list here
imagine
imagine
rachel maddow
calling joe biden
to make sure
that he would stop a violent
insurrection of him trying to overthrow
the government of the united states
and how
the [ __ ] political body in this
country would respond to rachel maddow
texting joe biden while he's trying to
commit a coup
to remain as president of the united
states with a violent insurrection
by
sicking his his crowd his rally on
congress why they're trying to certify
the results of election
that the states have already certified
by trying to get kamala harris to do
something that isn't possible that's not
in the constitution can you even [ __ ]
imagine if they found a text message
from rachel maddow doing that
to joe biden can you even [ __ ]
think about it close your eyes close
your eyes and think about it it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna happen
but here we are here we are with all
these text messages
not just from uh lawmakers because
that's one thing i want to talk about
here on the [ __ ] list today
you guys notice we got some new graphics
for the [ __ ] list roundup have you guys
noticed that they're nice i like them
there's a new theme song and everything
over there check it out the [ __ ] list
roundup go follow us on twitch
we air the [ __ ] list roundup every every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
and then i kind of do a shitless roundup
here on the show where we pick a topic
and you know i just do one of my [ __ ]
rants
because
because that's that's why because [ __ ]
em
and and today i i wanna i wanna dedicate
some time here so let's let's bring in
the uh
well let's see let's make it let's let's
bring in the videos the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends because you know
on the shitless roundup every every
weekday we go through uh tweety tweets
in the trendy trends but here on the
[ __ ] list here on the podcast we pick
out one topic and the topic is seditious
lawmakers um because there's a lot of
there's a lot of text flying around out
there liz cheney actually read a bunch
of
of of texts to mark meadows
during the contempt hearing that the
january 6 select committee had
so if you guys weren't watching if you
if you've been watching the eclipse [ __ ]
what happened was while they were voting
to hold mark meadows in uh in criminal
contempt to move it to the house floor
liz cheney spoke
and she broke news almost immediately
when she was speaking because she
started to read actual evidence
now the one reason why this is so
[ __ ] uh earth shattering number one
is because all the people out there that
i have doubted
that have doubted that the january 6
select committee was doing their job and
was going to get get to the heart of
this issue and smoke out any kind of uh
maybe not just
maybe not just evidence but criminal
acts possible seditious acts
and gonna make sure
that if there is rocks to be uncovered
that they're gonna uncover kind of shut
them the [ __ ] up didn't it
didn't it because they started to really
show hey we got the [ __ ] evidence and
this isn't all the evidence
because they kind of i thought one of
the most important part of the contempt
hearings was when adam schiff
started to screenshot
some of these text messages to mark
meadows and the most significant ones
were from lawmakers these are congress
people
and this was during the contempt hearing
one of the videos after the contempt
hearing is when the chairman benny
thompson was being interviewed by
reporters near an elevator
he was asked
are these members
of the house of representatives and he
said yes they are congress people
and he was also asked if these names are
going to be revealed and he said yes we
are going to reveal their names and i've
been saying this for [ __ ] weeks i've
been saying it for [ __ ] weeks
the reason why members of congress the
trump family have not been subpoenaed is
because they're the targets of the
investigation
that is how investigations work
the targets if they are subpoenaed are
some of the last to be subpoenaed
the targets of the investigation
the other news that i thought that was
very important that uh the congresswoman
lofgren of california
mentioned during the hearing while she
was speaking is that the january 6th
select committee is gonna have
recommendations for legislation
to make sure that january 6 never
happens again
i think that
with the congress people's tweets i at
the fox news [ __ ] and the donald j trump
jr [ __ ]
you know that's fine that's fine for it
to trend and to make them look [ __ ]
stupid but we knew we knew fox news is a
bunch of [ __ ] frauds
we knew they're a bunch of [ __ ]
frauds and they're not the [ __ ] news
and we knew that they wanted that the
cheeto dust mobster was going to have
his cheeto dust kangaroo coo
and when it all started to happen you
seen laura ingram tweet this looks bad
for all of us all of us
meaning fox news host how are we going
to explain this violent insurrection of
you trying to overthrow the government
of the united states
donald trump jr and sean hannity saying
it gone too far
like well we didn't we didn't want you
to actually try to commit a coup
grandpa poopy pants
we didn't want you to actually do it we
just wanted to pretend because that's
all this is it's it's we're at the
internet section of wrestlemania in real
life like i've been saying for [ __ ]
months and these people want to play
pretend
they want to play pretend it's not for
real they don't give a [ __ ]
but they've convinced a bunch of
delusional ivermectin facebook institute
followers
to believe all this [ __ ] there are
people
still waiting for jfk junior to show up
to run with donald trump to crown and
king or some dumb [ __ ] i don't know
there there's 30 people that went to the
cheesecake factory the think cheesecake
factory is the only place you can get
cheesecake
and they're pissed that they have to be
vaccinated cheesecake factory cheesecake
as far as i'm concerned i i think i've
been to cheesecake factory once in my
entire life i don't even [ __ ]
remember it
that's how great their cheesecake is
i'm i i didn't paint by cheesecake
factory i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't know how great it is i think
i've been there once i don't remember
it you [ __ ] anti-vaxx dumb bucks it's
probably not that great go get your
cheesecake someplace else go get it
delivered
order it make that [ __ ] at home would
you please
but it's the same [ __ ] kookiness
that he's
queuing on mike flynn
sydney powell lynnwood john eastman
rudy giuliani all these mark meadows all
these people
jeffrey clark steve bannon
the shock troops
these members of congress these
seditious members of congress and if
you're wondering who the people are that
the text messages are from they've
already given it away
it's already given away there's already
a list of members of congress that have
haven't that have had their text
messages and their metadata taken
that's who it is
it's the people who stand in front of a
microphone who who claim to protect the
the political prisoners of the january
six
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
the actual grunts that went and
committed the violent acts
at the capitol
but we have other evidence of these
people pre-planning it with video social
media videos and even lauren bobert
tweeting out the speaker of the house
her [ __ ] location
this isn't complicated
but liz cheney
liz cheney calls out uh
jim jordan on the floor
now this is this is pretty important and
significant
um because you got to remember when
they're doing floor debate you know
they're on either side right now they
set the microphones up to where uh they
could have liz cheney and adam kinzinger
speak
the people that are
that wanted to debate on the side of
sanity
they set a microphone up for them so
that uh these seditious members of
congress wasn't sitting behind them like
marjorie taylor greene paul goes-r
all these [ __ ]
sitting behind they didn't want them
sitting behind them
it looked like they're supporting them
so they set up two microphones for the
republicans
in the house debate
but jim jordan stands up and you know
gives the regular [ __ ] about
tourists and and it's uh overblown in
the january 6 select committee's
unconstitutional all kinds of nonsense
[ __ ] [ __ ] nonsense
talking about privacy and [ __ ] look
you don't have the right to privacy when
you commit crimes that's that's not a
thing
that's not a thing
i i just i can't [ __ ] fathom how
stupid this is but let's listen to what
liz cheney says and then i'll i'll
respond here some of the um charges that
my colleague from ohio just made which
are flat false she's talking to jim
jordan number one mr meadows refused to
show up for his deposition the committee
scheduled the deposition after extensive
coordination with mr meadows at a day
that he chose that he selected and then
he refused to show up and he refused to
show up to testify about non-privileged
questions so my colleague from ohio can
talk uh as much as he'd like about
executive privilege and about george
washington and about the extent to which
it's it's crucial for the survival of
the republic with which i agree
but we are talking here about testimony
about non-privileged materials
secondly madam speaker i would say that
we all on this side of the aisle used to
be
uh in agreement about what had happened
on january 6. there was a brief period
of time days perhaps when we were in
agreement
standing perhaps at this microphone
the minority leader kevin mccarthy said
this on january 13th
the president bears responsibility for
wednesday's attack on congress by mob
rioters
he should have immediately denounced the
mob when he saw what was unfolding
these facts require immediate action by
president trump
unfortunately mr mccarthy's position
changed on this issue ms mccarthy then
worked against voted against the
resolution that would have created a
bipartisan commission to investigate
these matters and he withdrew his
nominees to this committee
let me say that again he withdrew his
nominees to this committee
this committee is engaged in critical
investigative and legislative activity
for which there is no greater purpose in
terms of congress's responsibility no
matter what my colleague on the other
side may claim in terms of mr meadows
so there we have it
you have
it just
you can't you can't make this [ __ ] up um
and she slam dunks him in the trash now
don't get me wrong here i'm i'm no liz
cheney fan because uh you guys know that
i call her darth vader jr um because she
is she's no ally to liberals or the
liberal cause or even democracy for that
for that matter she just just the enemy
of our enemy is our friend type thing
right that's that's all this is
that's all this is and that that's
that's the most important part that you
have to remember here
is that the enemy of our enemy is our
friend right now and the reason why is
because darth vader jr liz cheney wants
to bury donald trump under a prison
somewhere for a long long time i mean a
long
long time
is what she wants to do
but i want to play here i also want to
play
the
um where she's reading the tweets
because we're going to talk about the
congressman tweets when we bring gabe on
here in just just a little bit
but right now i want to talk about the
significance of what liz cheney is
saying
and uh so let's let's go to this video
here
um
this video here is gonna show the
uh what she said during the contempt
hearing now you gotta remember uh benny
thompson brings us in as a contempt
hearing and then he throws to
to liz cheney he makes a lot of
statements that to make sure that the
public knows that they're going to get
to the bottom of this
but no come hell or high water rather it
requires them to hold 15 people in
criminal contempt or refer 15 people for
criminal contempt to department of
justice or if it's just the three uh
steve bannon jeffrey clark
and mark meadows now they've already
they also disclosed during this
committee uh committee hearing where
they're they're voting on contempt
charges to move to the floor of the
house
they also they also mention
that they've been interviewing hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds
of people
members of congress's staff even they
disclose and they have thousands and
thousands of pages of documents now this
is very important while they're why
they're holding mark meadows in contempt
and i believe this clip is going to show
it
up for lit when liz cheney starts to
talk here
but
when when you talk about when you talk
about the reason why they're holding
mark meadows in contempt the reason why
isn't because he willingly gave
privileged or non-privileged whatever
jim jordan was trying to say where she
slam dunked him in the trash on the last
clip
the reason why they're holding it in
contempt is because something changed
about mark meadows cooperating mark
meadows handed over all this evidence
we've seen this with the powerpoint they
were powerpointing a coup
they were powerpointing it they were
powerpointing the overthrowing of the
government of the united states
that was the thing that was happening
that's what they were doing
powerpointing it everyone knows you use
google slides or keynotes you don't use
powerpoint who the [ __ ] uses powerpoint
everyone knows if you're going to
overthrow a government use [ __ ]
google slides for crying out loud jesus
christ
well let's learn allah here indeed
according to the records multiple fox
news hosts
knew the president needed to act
immediately
they texted mr meadows
and he has turned over those texts
quote
mark
the president needs to tell people in
the capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
laura ingram wrote
please get him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished
brian kilmeade texted
quote can he make a statement ask people
to leave the capitol
sean hannity urged
as the violence continued
one of the president's sons
texted mr meadows quote
he's got to condemn this [ __ ] asap
the capitol police tweet is not enough
donald trump jr texted
meadows responded
quote i'm pushing it hard i agree
still
president trump did not immediately act
donald trump jr texted again
and again
urging action by the president
quote
we need an oval office address
he has to lead now
it has gone too far
and gotten out of hand end quote
but hours passed
without necessary action by the
president
these non-privileged texts are further
evidence
of president trump's supreme dereliction
of duty
during those 187 minutes
so i think we're gonna have uh uh this
187 minute thing continue because uh she
says it there so i think that's that's
gonna be a thing that they keep talking
about right uh they're gonna keep
talking about the 187 minutes that went
on and on and on and ticked on and on
because they're going to try to lay out
a timeline here and that's the most
important thing that i think the january
6 select committee is going to get to is
from the 187 minutes from when it
started to win it ended what the [ __ ]
happened who told what who told who who
knew what and why why did the cheeto
dust mobster who was the president at
the time
why did he not call the national guard
why did he not call off
his maggots
why why did he not try to stop the
insurrection now we all know the answer
to this question
we all know the answer to this question
that's not complicated
we know the answer to this question
because donald trump wanted to remain
dictator of the united states he wanted
to overthrow the government he wanted to
wipe his ass with the constitution
that's what he wanted we all know that
but in a criminal court
in a criminal court just knowing
something isn't good enough you have to
[ __ ] prove it so you have to have the
evidence to prove it and not only do you
have to have the evidence to prove it in
a criminal court you also have to have
the the evidence
to refer the matter
to the the house
floor for criminal referral to the
department of justice
because we can't just wipe our ass with
the constitution just because he did
so you have to gather up the evidence
now if you watch the the contempt
hearing which if you didn't watch it
it's okay you can go to the youtube
channel go to thetonymichaels.com go to
the youtube channel
i i did a special [ __ ] list roundup for
the contempt hearing alone so it's over
on the youtube channel
you can go watch the full contempt
uh hearing of mark meadows where they
start to lay out this evidence
but here in a minute we're gonna bring
in gabe
uh because we're gonna talk about
not just the [ __ ] text from the fox
news host but also the text from the
lawmakers
because i think that's all important
that is all encompassing and all
important and everyone needs to know
that uh not only i mean everyone again
this is the thing where everyone knows
that fox news is all [ __ ]
everyone knows it's all [ __ ] trump
propaganda machine everyone knows this
we've known this for years
now and really they've been in the
pocket of the trump propaganda machine
since 2016.
and we've known this
now they've been lying for much longer
and propagating for much longer
but now they can't run from it and
they're having a difficult time over
there at fox news
i'm running from the fact
running from the fact
that they are a propaganda machine
so
i think this all deserves
attention on the [ __ ] list
so stay right with us right here because
we're going to be right back we're going
to bring we're going to bring your
favorite your favorite executive
producer and gabe and i think i think we
we found a little i think we found a
little video on the internet you know
how we are we like to find these little
these little videos on the internet so
so stay right there don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
headlines
[Music]
president joe biden releases 50 million
barrels of oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve to lower gas prices
for american families
thanks brandon
[Applause]
[Music]
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
thanks for sticking with us here
we got gabe with us now
we're gonna go over some some of these
some more of these text messages
i know i know
i know gabe found this video somewhere
on the internet he posted it on his uh
he posted it on his uh
his twitter account i think he put it
over on your uh your tick tock too uh
didn't you
gabe gabe's gotta yeah there you go
technical difficult there we go uh no i
i only posted to
twitter and instagram right now i will
post to oh okay so all the tick tock
fans out there stay put he will get the
video that he found he will get it out
to
the the masses on the on the team
and honestly i wouldn't be surprised if
this
type of video the style of video finds
its way
back on the internet again for other
things you know maybe it's more text or
it might just be crazy q and on writing
posts so what you're saying is is
possibly this video there there could be
a series of these
that may be as done by the person that's
doing them because i noticed the
hairstyle of the person is is kind of
you know it's almost like this person
likes to wear wigs i don't know maybe
i'm almost i mean the color of the hair
is like you know gray like a silver fox
very distinguished right yeah well and
you know that the robe the pipe i mean
it all it all you know and you'll
so if you folks out there that are
listening to the podcast are only going
to hear this you really need to get on
twitter or instagram and really look at
this video that gave found because
it it is kind of nutty uh that this
person put this together but you're
saying you're saying that this is
possibly a series where this person's
gonna do these type of readings of these
texts possibly
yeah i mean i've i've heard whispers
right oh especially if the if the
committee
if the committee releases more text
messages that are pretty damning uh
right in terms of what was happening on
january 6th i wouldn't be surprised if
you know there's a sequel or a trilogy
or you know there's a whole there's the
whole saga really right it could be like
four hours of this [ __ ] right yeah this
could be
you know i could probably find a
director's cut too you know of just like
a narration over the narration right
well so so i i kind of gave my take on
the [ __ ] list here so let me get let me
get you to get a chance to give the
audience a take on what you what you
think of these uh these text messages
because i have a few videos i want to
play from the rules committee which i
think kind of got under the shuffle
there um especially if jamie raskin um
talking
specifically about mark meadows donald
trump jr some other stuff but let's get
your take first before we watch some of
those videos what it so what did you
make of some of these text messages what
do you think is some of the most
significant stuff that came out of that
well i think i mean one is that there is
a direct line from fox news hosts
to the cell phone of mark metals which
means you've got the you know the right
hand man to donald trump
uh the fact that they've got a direct
line of communication um
is a little bit frightening
um
and also i would say specifically
because the amount of influence that
they might have you know as you see
these text messages that come from
uh brian kilmeade
uh
you've got sean hannity uh laura
ingraham um you can see that there's
they they have a say in what's happening
here and how right they're trying to
they're trying to give orders right i
mean that's right exactly yeah they're
trying to you know
especially because they said like
everything that you worked for you know
you're destroying he's destroying his
legacy like these are all
words of flattery
to make
or at least uh
persuade him trump being who i'm talking
about to uh make an announcement right
they're like oh you know his son who
cannot get in touch with his dad by the
way
which is not surprising though is it
right not surprising totally uh totally
commonplace i think for that family the
only person i think would have a direct
line would be ivanka
and uh i look at it and i'm like
you know it's hilarious that his son
can't even get in contact with his own
dad he's sending multiple texts to mark
meadows to tell him to send to make an
oval office address you've got fox news
hosts that are trying to
be like
get them away from the capitol it's
giving us a bad look a bad image you
know giving us a
right laura ingraham said that she said
you're it's gonna hurt all of us and
right and i think
i think back to your point because i've
been making the point uh yesterday and
today
that um you know she thought she was
going to suffer but maybe you're right
in that when they're barking orders it's
almost like the fox news host uh
killmead uh laura ingram sean hannity
are producing the trump show right right
like yeah because because i'm not saying
they're a puppeteer but they certainly
have some influence going on right
they're producing this trump reality
show right and maybe that is maybe
that's their role in this game is that
they're trying to to produce this show
because i i actually
um
i suggested that maybe they wanted it to
go up to a certain point for the pretend
look right because i always say we're at
the we're at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life right exactly
and and and a lot of this is well i know
it's not true but i'm gonna pretend that
it's true because you know that feels
great like yeah and not to demean anyone
who's a wrestling fan but that's kind of
the wrestling thing is like well we know
it's not real but we want to root for it
and pretend like it is that's the fun in
it right yeah so it's exactly like don't
actually fight but make it look like
we're fighting right and so i think for
them specifically they want to give this
image that like we're fighting for our
freedoms and our right to you know
object
the
uh the the
um
the
uh yeah the election results yeah yeah
so i'm blanking uh yes to to um certify
the election results and i think that
right there there is this a there's this
again this perception or at least this
creation of an alternate reality this
you know
uh
wrestlemania if you will
where they're trying to be like you know
for the same reason that like margery
taylor green and matt gates are up doing
a press conference last week saying like
we're gonna fight for the j6 group that
are in prison right it's all the show
to give the impression
that they are actually doing
what their constituent or or what they
their constituents want them to do or at
least the the the image or the facade
that they are actually doing something
well right i mean we've seen it today
from ron desantis when he's
talking about crt again oh some kind of
stop woke actor right just complete
[ __ ] nonsense exactly so i think it's
all it's all show and it's all like you
know it's all jazz hands is what it is
right and i think at the end of the day
like
so going back to the original question
you asked me like what do i think was
most serious i those are pretty serious
but i also think the fact that there
were lawmakers in the chambers texting
back and we're like we're under siege
the [ __ ] is going down we are [ __ ]
like i'm sure that's right contexts that
are like very explicit where they're
like what the [ __ ] is going on someone
get us out of here so you're saying
you're saying not the congress people
who are probably complicit in
organizing and planning and wanting to
continue this you're saying the text
message from the congress people telling
the white house hey [ __ ] turn
this off yeah those are the people and
the people that could be
directly or you know indirectly uh
complicit with what was happening what
was planned
may have been in those chambers right
right you've got uh
uh well yeah you got goes-r green gats
all the the gene team as i call gomer
yeah exactly
um and so you've got them either outside
inside where have you and you've got the
people that are inside texting to be
like
what the [ __ ] is going on you've got
people with guns that are you know
barricading the door the [ __ ] is getting
intense right they're breaking windows
they're vandalizing well and at some
point it's reported that someone was
shot i was watching that day like i go
back every once in a while and look at
the videos that i made that day because
i made videos before it happened and i
made some videos after it happened um
but i was watching it as it was
happening live and at one point they
were reporting that someone was shot and
killed
like when that when ashley babbitt was
shot and killed that was one of the ones
one of the first um reports of a death
right because
i mean she was i don't know if you've
seen the video but if you watch the
video she's pretty much they um she dies
right there i mean it's yeah it's pretty
brilliant
it's a close range shot they're not
when she's trying to jump through the
window right well i mean she's jumping
through the window that was broken uh
through this area that is supposed to be
a secure area for the congress people
this officer is trying to protect him i
mean he doesn't know what's on the other
side he doesn't know what she's carrying
in her backpack he doesn't know her
intentions yeah i mean it it it was all
chaos and really honestly now that we
look at some of these text messages and
stuff we know that mark meadows donald
trump and some of these congress people
they got they got ashley babbitt killed
they're the ones that got her killed um
yeah so let's
let's play first this video
the video video that you found on the
internet internet video i think i
combined those two idiom that maybe
internet video yeah internet video
new word throw it in webster's yeah
right right yeah well you know we can
make we can make [ __ ] up we can make
this up as we go along everyone else is
picking up [ __ ] yeah what [ __ ] jfk is
coming back crt is a real thing
so let's play the [ __ ] video hello
and welcome to a dramatic reading of
text messages sent to mark meadows on
january 6th can he make a statement
ask people to leave the capitol
fox news host sean hannity please get
him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished
fox news host brian kilmeade mark the
president needs to tell people in the
capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
fox news host laura ingram he's got to
condemn this [ __ ] asap
the capitol police tweet is not enough
we need an oval office address
he has to lead now
it has gone too far and gotten out of
hand
donald trump jr and this has been a
dramatic reading of text messages sent
to mark meadows on january 6th
so so a couple couple things about this
video that you found i don't know where
you found this but but one thing is the
oh holy night in the background that
really is like really makes it
christmassy with the fire going and
everything like right i really thought
that this person you know
right they just lit a fire they're
playing the music in the background like
they're fully committed to this to
reading these messages the other thing i
really like that i'm gonna criticize
this person too um number one brian
kilmeade they said that name beautifully
i don't know because i actually kill mid
kill me kill me i know but that way they
broke it up but i've heard i i'm gonna
criticize this person maybe they should
have said ingraham because i've heard
have you heard that some people i call
her england
yeah is it ingraham or is it ingram
which is it it's it's ingram it's right
that's why i i was also curious myself
you know as someone who is a critic of
that witch um i
went online and i looked up
how it said and people oh so after
viewing after viewing the video you made
sure that it was pronounced correct yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
i've i've stumbled through some
interviews where people like
laura ingram
and they've also said you're right no no
not ingraham i mean i think people are
like fanatically like ingraham and then
people are like no no it's ingram
uh but that's what the internet show has
shown me even if you like so you've
never heard anyone say ingraham i've
heard i mean i'm sure right we have yeah
probably because there's you know
there's saying all the letters out so
that's that that's the non-proper way to
see her is ingraham because i think
that's the way i'm going to say it from
now on then yeah no say it wrong say it
wrong i mean like
ingra ingram pig is what yeah there you
go
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
i don't know where you found this video
but i hope i hope there is more of uh
yeah i i hope so too and i i wouldn't be
surprised that if more of these text
messages um
it's
find themselves out in public so let's
let's actually show i've got um let me
see here let me uh try to get this um
let's see if we can uh pull up this
i want to pull up a tweet here a video
uh you know you know i like the
the uh the videos
so let's pull this video up here
and we can um show the folks
let's see there we go okay so this is
jamie raskin um
and it is during the this is during the
rules committee okay so so so if folks
at home don't know
uh what happens is is the
contempt hearing has happened in the
select committee they vote to move it to
the floor but to move it to the floor
they have to establish the rules of the
floor debate so that's what this
committee does is establish the rules
for the floor debate and that's what's
happening here
is jamie raskin is presenting the select
committee's case of the rules and what
the rules are in the rules committee so
let's listen to this clip here and then
we'll talk about a whole set of messages
that were discovered
in asking questions to mr meadows
including republican lawmakers
and others sending frantic messages
saying we are under siege up here at the
capitol they have breached the capital
mark protesters are literally storming
the capital breaking windows on our
doors rushing in is trump going to say
something
there's an armed standoff at the house
chamber door
we are all helpless here's some more
this one came from laura ingraham it was
identified mark the president needs to
take people
to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
brian kill me
please get him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished sean hannity can he make a
statement
ask people to leave the capitol donald
trump jr he's got to condemn this
experiment asa
capitalist tweet
donald trump jr we need an oval office
address he has to lead now it has gone
too far and gotten out of hand a whole
set of messages so i actually um i'm i'm
one to believe that the um and maybe i'm
wrong here but the response back from
the donald trump
that that jamie raskin read there
he he res cause that is i think that's a
significant text too it's not the ones
that are coming in it's also that one
that goes out because mark meadows
tweet our tweets text back to donald
trump jr and says
he says
i'm trying my damnedest right like i'm
trying really hard over here but it's
not [ __ ] working right in other words
now again it's hard to tell with these
[ __ ] lying pieces of [ __ ] what what
is truth in these texts probably because
they're probably lying to each other
they lie to us why wouldn't they lie to
each other but mark meadows is being
genuine in that text back to donald
trump jr that hey man i'm trying
everything i can this [ __ ] maniac
over here wants to keep it going right
right like like maybe trump led them
down this road
where he they're like oh we'll pretend
to have a coup and then he's like no i
really want to have a cue at some point
i don't know well i think the other
thing too is i was thinking about this
the other day when i was uh
when i was driving is
the
the moments when people are trying to
say hey
shut the [ __ ] down say something make a
video make it official
i think through everything was happening
like it was like oh yeah we're gonna do
this thing and we're gonna show everyone
that you're so strong and he's like yeah
great sounds awesome right and then you
know the question of like will it really
happen kind of is like like loosely
floated but once it starts happening
and he sees the amount of people that
are willing to literally break into the
capital for him
i think it's a goddamn rush of euphoria
and narcissism and all of that and
everything else and just like just he's
like oh my god this might work right
right it was we were supposed to pretend
but this might work and then right and i
think also like he's been he's been
beaten down uh
legally in case by case especially by
you know trump appointed judges which
backfired on him for these people that
are trying to and he's [ __ ] pissed
right and he's pissed and he's sad and
he's
you know i believe at one point they
were uh people inside were saying that
the oval office stenched of
of uh
yeah yeah anyway but he just i mean like
the guy is eating away he was held up
wait wait wait wait don't don't just
don't just breeze over the fart fast
stuff okay that's good material here so
what you're saying is so the reports are
that that the fish sandwiches uh the
fish fillets the big macs are causing
are causing grandpa poopy pants the the
mustang or the the mango mussolini jesus
to have flatulence and he's held up in
this room and he's yeah you know he's
got like his parents and aids probably
going through like yankee candles trying
to like and like incense and and sage
trying to just like clear out the space
right uh
the clear the farts is what you're
saying definitely exactly and i'm sure
like you know how when they switch the
the white house they have all the
decorations ready and they have all this
you know prices and furniture and they
switch it over within a very few you
know few hours during like
boom like right yeah and i'm sure they
spent extra time in the oval office to
like really like steam the rugs and like
just do the walls and like see you know
it's like when somebody smokes and you
walk into home and like they smoked so
much in their home they cannot get the
smell out i'm sure it's very much like
you gotta rip that drywall down yeah
yeah yeah
i'm sure they've got a segment for like
tlc kind of like right right like the
the flip this house or whatever yeah
exactly right well i i didn't mean to i
didn't mean to get us off on a uh
it matters here when we're talking about
these these text messages
but right well i i think it i think it
does matter because it also goes back to
this whole thing the guy is is like
going through like
grief and depression and sadness and
anger it's the mindset the mindset of
him right right and what's happening in
the moment yeah he keeps losing he just
keeps on losing like he cannot win then
january 6th happens everyone is [ __ ]
pumped and they're gonna we're like
we're gonna storm the capitals like yes
you know my people it actually happens
we're on january 6 [ __ ] goes [ __ ] a w
like just just batshit crazy and he
looks at it and he goes they're willing
to fight for they're willing to kill for
me
they love the chaos that i want right
right and then he makes announcement and
he goes i love you all you know all that
[ __ ] right because he feels that
they he he's like oh they love me they
they will do anything for me right you
know it's like the question of like oh
if you love me so much would you kill
for me and that is literally what they
did they were so in love and so
fixated in his cult and trump in this
ideology that they were willing to lose
themselves
for some dumb greater purpose that they
thought was right and i think trump saw
it and as he sees this whole thing lay
out he was like this is getting serious
but this
i like i like this
this actually and his dumbass you know
mental uh kind of state
um
thinks that
he actually has a fighting chance if
they do this
then he can overturn the election
because someone somewhere that it was it
was going to work
and then he looked at connie spinner
rudy giuliani who was right exactly
right
yeah and whether it was like legitimate
or not in the way that they're just
trying to like appease him or really be
serious with him he looks and he goes
this is actually possibility and then
you got mark meadows who whether or not
he's like the person that when you're
like going to meet someone like oh i i'm
i'm stuck in traffic or like i just left
the house but i'll be there you know and
like but really they haven't even left
the house yet
i don't know to your point if he's
really being serious with don don jr
or if he's just kind of like
uh
[Music]
buffering a bit of a distance to like
i'm dealing with that i'm dealing with
it and meanwhile trump is like locked in
the bathroom doing a line of adderall
and like
[ __ ] tweeting trying to figure out
how he's gonna trying to figure out how
this chaos is gonna benefit him right oh
my god what what what a what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show what a [ __ ] [ __ ] show well
uh i i guess i guess we'll uh we'll know
this as this takes on and as we get to
some of these other public hearings of
the january 6 select committee uh but uh
everyone stay right here we're gonna be
right back with heather gardner and our
interview and our and and also trivia
but uh
after after we have trivia i want you to
stay around because me and gabe are
gonna talk about the bone end of the
week so
stay right there don't go anywhere we'll
be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binder is brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of women
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast i appreciate you staying with us
for the interview we have a special
guest here for you today
a very very special guest
last night's late night on quibby
entertainment weekly huffington post
yahoo entertainment minus media network
and now the host of occupy democrats
trivia show heather gardner is here to
join us thank you for joining us heather
hi that was quite the introduction thank
you for making me sound so good
we are thank you for coming on the show
yes the first question i have because i
want you to tell us about this new
trivia show that you have going on
because i see a green screen behind you
and i'm assuming that maybe maybe this
green screen has something to do with
this trivia show so tell us about occupy
democrats trivia it definitely does and
i'm nervous about this green screen
because this is new technology that
we're implementing and um it makes me
nervous every time i add new technology
to things as i'm sure you guys you have
the system you set me up here with it
looks great i don't know how to work it
so it makes me nervous
but yes we'll be standing in front of
this green screen um and yeah the occupy
democrats trivia show is
really really fun it's the first of its
kind which really excited me about doing
this project and basically it's it's a
mix of trivia late night television
obviously with a political progressive
slant and we you know we thought about
when we were doing this show like when
we were coming up with this idea for the
show we were like you know people need
to be engaged especially the democrats
you know i know that the republicans
they have their fear-mongering um
[ __ ] factory called fox news we
don't have that and we're like well how
can we get people engaged what if we
paid them actual money to listen
to what we say and make a game show out
of it um which is
wild and crazy and also this is where we
are in the world so yeah i mean
basically the occupy democrats trivia
show is going to you know pick a pick a
topic go through a bunch of facts like
um if you watch my content it's
explainer video style but this is much
longer and then we're gonna answer
questions along the way and we're
actually giving away a thousand dollars
every single night and we're gonna have
up to a hundred winners so at least um i
mean at most 100 people will get 10
bucks um and then you know we've done
this we did some test shots and stuff
some test shows one time one person one
person was the only one who knew all the
answers so they walked away with a
hundred or a thousand dollars and then
like the next night like three people
won so they walked away with like 333
dollars like we're giving away some
serious cash to learn some things about
our nation this is george soros money
right obviously yes obviously yes as you
can see it's very well funded fully
funded with the push yeah state of the
art yeah so did george pay for did did
george pay for the push pins or you know
that one specifically came out of my
budget okay
he's kind of a cheap guest
[Laughter]
are you listening george are you
listening
heather's waiting on her antipates for
that check in the mail
right right i i mean i even laminated my
antifa card i bought a fanny pack
specifically to carry that thing around
expecting george to start sending the
checks and i haven't got one yet and i
even laminated my [ __ ] card it didn't
happen i know we were we were talking
about this beforehand but it is such a
common like misconception misconception
that you know we are being paid by
george soros but that we're being right
at all
right right
i mean i'm not i don't know about you
guys but i'm not being paid
i i
yeah for like the last two years i don't
know why people think like oh content
creators oh you showed up here you
showed up there you must be rolling in
the money like no that's why i want you
to go to the merge store and buy the
merch that's why i want you to like uh
you know give to the patreon because
that's the only way we get paid is if
you're watching us and you're viewing us
and you appreciate our content by you
pitching in a bit that's like a lot of
times that's the only way well that's
been the craziest thing about like this
shift that i did because you know i did
my my quivi show was a network
television show like and i've always
done yahoo and huff posts like these are
well established organizations that
actually have budgets and i actually did
make a great salary doing all these
things but then the pandemic changed
everything and so you know and then i
lost my job during the pandemic as well
and nothing i mean i'm in los angeles
there has been
so few um opportunities over the last
two years because of the pandemic and so
we've been doing our content on the side
well actually it became our full-time
job at this point job i use lightly
because i cannot figure out how to make
money off of this i know people do it i
know that influencers exist and you know
people are making money somehow but i
haven't figured it out
where's your where's your bam energy
drink is your bam energy drink in the
background there by the uh
brought to you by coffee every single
morning
i need to get this generic coffee
what's in that coffee heather there's
gotta be i see some stuff back there
there's gotta be some maybe we should
okay good good good good this party
going yeah
well you gotta have the alcohol when
you're making content yeah because like
i said i don't have bills so you know
something's gotta mask my set so you so
you're talking about the the last
night's late night on quibby and some of
the other things that you've done so
tell us about those things
and you said the pandemic affected them
so tell us about what you were doing and
then what happened with the pandemic and
then what made you decide hey i'm gonna
just go all head into this content
creation because you did catch on
regardless if sorrels was paying the
bills or not you did catch on and you
did create a lot of attention to your
content so tell us about that sure so i
mean
2020 just back it up rewind you know
almost two years at this point which is
wild um yeah so 2020 we had just moved
back from uh new york city actually
because i was doing my show with
huffpost for a while that ended right as
shows do with things ebb and flow in the
entertainment industry um so i was
unemployed for uh a few months and then
you know quit the quibby opportunity
came up it was a network and we all know
like what happened to quibby but at the
time it was like the biggest you know
shaker that was going to shake up all
the industry and everything and um i got
my very own show uh it was that was a
lifelong dream of mine it was everything
that i had worked for in my 10 years
leading up to this because i got my
traditional um journalism television
hosting degree i went to smaller markets
and i came in l.a cut my teeth then i
went to manhattan and then finally
finally finally got like every single
thing that i had like worked for and
wanted and that lasted about two weeks
and you know um it's so funny i love i
love telling the story especially now
that we're removed from it where it
doesn't make me just sad and cry but
right we were actually i mean i had a
giant studio multi-million dollar studio
i had a dressing room i had a stylist i
had a team of producers like really the
dream the dream and i'm on
my set filming some commercials which is
also wild i never thought that i would
be like filming commercials for my show
with my name right on a network and i
put my phone away for an hour to go do
that and that was the day that tom hanks
um came down with it and that was the
day that the jazz game stopped the nba
shut down and it was all hap it all
happened in that hour and so i came back
and i was on the highest of highs yeah
i mean like just you're gonna be a big
star you're gonna be this is my best
moment and i just you got your rocket
launcher on it is are you ready oh i was
ready uh and then i picked up my phone
and then everything crashed and burned
right back to reality right back to
reality and so there was a little knock
on my door and it was my executive
producer
um and he was like hey so i know we were
supposed to come in tomorrow but you
know we're going to take a beat this
covered thing is like karna we're just
we're just taking precautions give us
just a week you know and we'll we'll
figure everything out
yeah sure sure
went back
oh wow
now but i was i mean i was devastated i
really really was and you know the show
did go on for about nine months um after
that so which is honestly i'm so so so
thankful for because so many people in
my industry like if i the timing of that
was wild because it was two weeks i got
that job and signed my contract to my my
five year contract by the way my five
years
five years turned into two weeks was
really ambitious um
no but you know i signed my contract
just two weeks before all of this
happened and so a lot of my friends who
didn't have contracts and you know as as
you guys know in the entertainment
industry a lot of work is freelance work
and you don't have these big deals you
know
i certainly didn't have one like this my
i worked for 10 years to get one like
this and um i just i was very very
fortunate to be able to still do the
show albeit from my house like where
where we are right now and um we did the
show remote for you know another six
months or whatever until quippy finally
finally you know died rest in peace um
but during that time
during that time we were obviously very
frustrated the entire world was
frustrated we were frustrated um sad and
unsure about everything and we just
started you know seeing donald trump
saying drink bleach and we started just
posting videos my husband and i because
he's an executive producer we never
worked together until this point we just
had our separate career paths and then
we were like well this is what we do we
are bored out of our [ __ ] minds like
let's bring some videos and you know we
weren't my show last night's late night
was with entertainment weekly really
uppity i mean it was about late night
television but me like my role wasn't
necessarily to talk about the political
stuff i let the big wigs do that the
john oliver and jimmy fallon and colbert
they got to do that so i wanted to speak
a little bit on it too and so we just
turned on the camera one day um
i got a little a message from
a gen z in my inbox on instagram and was
like hey have you heard of tick tock you
should post your videos there
and so i did and
for i don't know how he convinced me i
was just desperate i guess i don't know
bored and um four videos later we went
viral we went from 10 followers to 10
000 followers overnight wow and i've
never nothing like that has ever
happened in my decades long career and
we just like i mean from that second we
were hooked and we were like
let's do this like we my the network
quibby i know that like a lot of there's
a lot of jokes and a lot of you know
bad you know criticism about them and
stuff but let me tell you
i will take this with me to the grave
they were the best company i ever worked
for and they were so supportive so so so
supportive of the work that we were
doing you know and they never once like
as i've worked at plenty of places even
progressive ones um that did not want me
to have a certain opinion or any opinion
really your role is to just kind of
report the facts and move on and then
you don't get an opinion and they were
like yeah let's go for it and of course
this was when black lives matter was
happening and there was i felt like i
wanted to say a lot and they let us they
let us do it and you know and so we we
took
that was around the summer time and then
could be ended a few months later and
then from there
it was really depressing because there
was like typically you know a show ends
and your agent or whatever i have an
agent and manager you know they you know
all right well we're gonna line you up
with this meeting and we're gonna send
you off to this audition
there was nothing nothing
nothing happening it was right around
the holidays like honestly this time
last year and so we were like well
we got nothing better to do
let's just keep going with this and see
what we can do um and we've been doing
it now we got a camera we can edit
videos and we can post them baby let's
just let's just go for it and it's so
funny because people are like oh wow
like you were so brave to make that
choice i'm like
i have a choice
the only option was to keep going with
this or watch netflix for the next year
because there were no jobs you know to
be had so right here
you made your own job well and
that's kind of
that's kind of where you know i i came
in to this at the same time last year
right after the election i was i
discovered this tick tock and i and i
did all the dancing videos and stuff
gabe did too hey listen heather if you
want to go down to get no this is not
true
just go all the way down don't believe
him
go all the way down go all the way down
his feet he has the the dancing videos
are there you should go watch them gabe
i'm surprised he's taking him down yet
no no no no no no i i'm always promoting
him
he keeps pushing people to watch them i
don't know where they are
right they're down there
so
so uh you know i did the whole dancing
video the trendy whatever the hell that
thing is right on tick tock and then and
then i got so pissed off at the election
that this whiny little [ __ ] wouldn't
shut up and just you know can see you
know right do what do what everyone does
when they lose it's just lose
so i started yelling and screaming into
the tick tock and i kind of
you know people like them so i kept
going
and i i think
i think a lot of um
a lot of folks don't really understand
that when you're when you're trying to
find a creative outlet and you find this
this little thing and maybe tick tocks
it maybe a certain you know maybe you're
painting or something else or making
books we'll talk about that in a second
um but the
when you have an outlet like this
there's sometimes not a mission right
but sometimes there is a mission
so what i want to know about your new
trivia show with occupy democrats
is what is the main mission of that show
what what are you trying to accomplish
and what do you want the audience to see
do other than to win tons of cash
obviously yeah i mean without hours a
day that's that's no small amount of
cash
right exactly so it's so it's every
single day yeah so it's going to be a
week because you know christmas is
coming up and people are busy so we're
doing a week of shows with occupy
democrats for this week and then we're
gonna you know reassess for the new year
and think about different ways to
improve and everything so yeah i mean it
really is a trial and error which i
don't think people realize that about
like how fast things can change and how
about like creating content is just like
on the fly like with you know with
traditional television whatever it takes
it could take weeks months even to get
some sort of idea on off the ground you
know from conception to actually air oh
no no no we have like a day
figure everything out which is it's
really fun actually um but yeah but um
the mission behind this you know it's
funny we actually did pretty early on
think about like what our mission was my
husband and i
lauren my executive producer who does
all this with me we're equal partners in
this well shout out shout out that's
right equal
i mean look who's look who's here and
who's not right
[Laughter]
you know you know you know our mantra on
the show is [ __ ] them so you know
exactly exactly um no but we really did
actually think about like what do we
want to accomplish especially because at
the time i was still under contract with
you know a network and i'm representing
you know i was at the time representing
um them and you know our first and
foremost
was education because it was so
frustrating and i think i think we all
feel that frustration still um with how
much misinformation exists out there and
how easy it is to especially at the time
when the news was we were just watching
cnn or msnbc or even fox sometimes to
see what was going on i mean 24 hours a
day it was just on in the background
while we were going about our lives and
it was just so frustrating to see people
miss the important things or or get
something wrong and it's not even just
like random people on the internet like
i was dealing with my family members and
friends you know who were being sucked
into this and so our first and foremost
thing was education like we are going to
give you the straight facts of it which
is why
from the very beginning of our videos
we've always included every single
source that we cite you know we make we
make educated we only educated points we
only use reputable sites i'm not here
doing you know joe schmo blog post dot
com
[Laughter]
i like joe schmoe some people do it's an
educated guy you know and so eddie he
does his own research he does his own
research that's right that's what we
want you to do do your own research
so anyway um education first and then
entertainment and comedy second and
that's really kind of the focus of
occupy democrats too and everything
we've done is education first and that's
you're going to laugh you're going to
learn something you know you're going to
laugh but you're also going to learn
something and that's the main point of
this like i said it's kind of um
it's an explainer like game show you're
going to get the facts and we're going
to we just structured it in a way that
you get to participate in learning those
those facts which i think is pretty cool
i'm i'm really stoked about it i i i'm
actually really excited about it because
i've seen a video
and i think i pulled it off the internet
somewhere here of somebody there's a lot
of videos on the internet
talking about well see this person uh
did a christmas song because we're
coming up on christmas here and this
person did a christmas song and it seems
like um this is uh
something on fox news war on christmas
you know the the typical type fox news
uh real factual information you know
what i'm talking about totally but
someone
so so let me let me play this video that
i found and that maybe you can tell us
about it on the other side
we're beginning to fight the war on
christmas
just like a year ago
we'll say merry christmas
never stopped but we'll pretend the
traditions dead and blame it all on joel
we've pretended that there's a war on
christmas
since
[Music]
[Music]
white house wearing suits manufactured
disputes and fake out verge on fox and
friends laura will squawk and tucker
will shock white supremacy they will
defend and next year will rinse and
repeat and do this bit again
go ahead and give us a response on the
war that the video wore on christmas i
don't know who that girl is but she's
real talented
[Laughter]
you know there is there is a similarity
between that with this with this video
between you and gabe gabe loves his wigs
and uh i know this whole box i love them
so much i don't know names i've named
them i'm that person i'm sorry
i just
so do you you feel like you're a little
bit like myra in in shits creek like
every one of them has a name and they've
got yeah and it's so funny you put it on
and i'm just like a completely different
person
and i love it so much it might be
but though it might be a little bit
different for you for me uh i put on a
wig and i still have my uh my facial
hair so you know there's that i don't
really have that problem
yeah yeah yeah like if i really cared
about it i would shave and somebody
asked me uh not too long ago they're
like
uh
why don't you like shave when you play
like some female character and i'm like
listen if and and all the female
characters that i play are typically
ones of like fox news republicans
whatever and i was like if i respected
that party
at all i would
but for people like lauren bober and
margie taylor green i'm gonna keep the
facial hair on i'm gonna just that
that's just that's just the look in the
field that i have going for it but yeah
i agree with you the wig like you put it
on and your whole different my
girlfriend will ask me questions and
i'm in character you know and the whole
thing and i've got people across the
street if the windows are open and i've
got the like because the windows from
the street
come straight in
and i've got the green screen so i might
be i might be like putting on the
uh like my tan bra you know and then
putting on a blouse and people walking
by you know get a little bit of a show
that you know that's how it goes that is
one thing that happened um we started
doing parody songs pretty early on i
don't remember what the first one was oh
it was like a covered world with a whole
new world when disney refused down in
florida refused to close remember that
[ __ ] rhonda
um anyway but then we got you know
better at it we got the wig and my my my
apartment at the time we we had just
moved in like i said like two weeks we
moved from manhattan we had no furniture
all we had was equipment
in our house like we were lucky we were
lucky to have a couch we had nothing
else i stood up for six months eating
food because we didn't have a table we
didn't have nothing so anyway but we had
all these lights and we just set the wig
because we didn't even have like a
storage like this didn't exist nothing
existed we didn't have a place to put
anything and the wig was just standing
on like a mic stand and my neighbor had
been gone for like a month as people did
during this time and she came back and
she was like she's walking by and she's
like
so i have to ask
is this something like sexy
like i got this whole like home alone
scheme going on over here i got a i got
a
cardboard cutout and a train when we
revealed that we just you know became
overnight tick tock stars and she got
even more concerned
[Laughter]
oh jesus so she thinks you're doing like
like these these sex videos on tick tock
she's like who are these people right
right and gabe's neighbors gabe's
neighbors are like look at this soros
antifa guy over here is this what antifa
does this is what we soros people i mean
they're getting free shows so you know
socialism right
i love it i love it so much
i am i am i am so happy that we have you
here and the reason why is because we
always play a trivia game on our show so
it is kind of like this trifecta thing
where we are going to have
a game show host playing trivia on the
tony michaels podcast but not only that
we are going to play we are going to
play game show trivia
[Music]
now to tell you we're not as high tech
as you we don't have like the we do not
have all that crazy stuff i don't know
you just i don't know like i said i have
an executive producer sitting right
there thank god he's around i don't know
anything um here's here's the rules
for game show trivia rules are i'm going
to ask five multiple choice questions
each question is worth one point okay
first one to ring in on their buzzer
will get a chance to answer the question
get it wrong and your opponent will have
a shot for the point whoever has the
most points after the five questions
wins are you ready let's do this
let's play
game show trivia
question number one
now remember these are multiple choice
questions
the very first tv game show was based on
a radio quiz show that aired in 1940
it first appeared on tv in 1950.
are you guys that old the contestants
were asked questions and if they
couldn't answer them correctly were
required to perform silly stunts like in
a tick tock as a consequence
what is the name of this game show is it
a a moment of truth
b
truth or consequences
c truth or dare or d instant recall i'm
gonna go with b truth and consequences
that seems logical that is correct that
is correct
that is correct i feel like back then
that was my that was like i was like i
feel like if there's anything that's
gotta be that one because i almost feel
like they're like game shows let's just
we're not even gonna be creative it's
just gonna be that the premise of the
show is the title which i know that's
right that's right like here it's called
game right our
[ __ ] graphic says game it's the game
network you know at this point you have
to be really really simple because
everything you any name that you come up
with has already been taken
right exactly right and there's a
website the url thing it's a whole thing
it's a whole thing okay question number
two
and and the question is going to give
this away of how it's structured but
but it's it's i've got some you know i
got some nostalgic ones like the last
one i have some updated ones question
number two the answer
this quiz show hosted by alex trebek
featured contestant kim jennings who
set an unprecedented record for winning
74 consecutive wins in 2004. the
question
which show is this is it a knockout
is it b
is it is it b cram
[Laughter]
is it c winning streak
or is it d jeopardy it's real tough
but i'm gonna you know go out on a limb
here jeopardy
d is correct
how did you ever how did you ever guess
i believe the
the correct answer uh i don't wanna
correct you tony it would have been what
is
jeopardy no no that's not correct
because i said i said number two is the
answer and then i asked the question at
the end
i made sure to structure that one and i
totally did not steal these off the
internet totally did not know you're
very definitely writer
i wrote every single one of these
questions and researched them for days
trust me
okay question number three
heather is in the lead question number
three one of the earliest game shows was
televised from 1952 to 1967.
the premise of the show consisted of
contestants whispering his or her secret
into the host ear the audience was clued
in to the secret but a panel of
celebrities had to guess the secret from
asking questions do you remember the
name of this game show was it a
i've got a secret was it b rumor has it
rumor has it was it c
play your hunch or was it d family
secrets at first i was gonna say
hollywood squares but i was like no
that's been uh
yeah uh okay so was it a i've got a
secret was it b
rumor has it
c play your hunch or d
family secrets
yeah see part of me is like i want to go
a but then rumor has it feels like a
little trick i'll go with b
rumor has it wrong heather
heather
you you get tossed the questions you now
have a chance for the point a i've got a
secret b rumor has it
c player hunch or d family secrets
say b that was but no no i'm gonna say
what you did
okay
i've got a secret is correct oh thank
you gabe for getting that wrong
yeah i know it's all good at least i was
in the right i was in the right area
right yeah
when you were talking about it i could
visualize that because my grandparents
loved what's that the game show network
oh my gosh they watched it all the time
and so i could visualize it but i didn't
know the name so i think i think there's
uh uh a pop culture reference in the
movie with leonardo dicaprio and tom
hanks you were speaking of tom hanks
earlier
um called again touch me became the very
first
uh
uh abignale jr appears on the game show
and i i don't think that's the one but
um it makes me think of that like
because i i never watched like old
episodes right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because you had to guess which which one
was the actual truth in a lie right or
something like that yeah yeah
yeah i don't know
but i remember they they all they said
that they were different they they
they're like i'm so-and-so or like i'm
william now right
and then you had to guess which one who
was yeah right and they're like so i
don't think that's i've got a secret but
i think that's sort of how it was you
know game shows are game shows right
they're very excited there are some very
weird game shows out there i've
definitely seen there are really really
odd ones uh
that you can still find to this day on
on youtube where people are like what
the [ __ ] was this about right
like there's a name
right exactly everyone there's like
always an audience and they're getting
pleasure off of someone else's like
despair and sadness and and at the end
it's like hopefully you win for instance
there was one that i watched uh not too
long ago on youtube um and i'm blanking
on the name but
there's a series of questions
and the host is asking you these
questions get more and more personal and
more and more intimate uh revealing
secrets that maybe your
family or partner don't even know
and there was one where basically it was
revealed that this woman had an affair
and it was
revealed on this episode and then the
dude came out and it was it was like
correct you know and then she wanted to
keep jerry springer it does but
but with money
yeah
right right right well it's a [ __ ] show
for sure but you know yeah whole new
yeah you know what that might have been
the name of the show it's called [ __ ]
show that's what it was well i do the
[ __ ] list with the [ __ ] show i don't
know maybe that's that's good okay
question number four
now now gabe heather is in the lead here
but with the bonus question that we have
you may be able to tie
but she isn't the leader oh okay
question number four
one of my favorite game shows was one
that combines celebrities
with the game of tic-tac-toe
peter marshall was the original host of
this game show
which show was it is it a
shoot for the stars is it b hollywood
squares is it c
tic tac doe
or is it or is it d
celebrity squares uh the answer is
hollywood squares it is it's b is
hollywood square probably wouldn't have
known that if you didn't give it away
earlier
we're like we'll get to that
we'll get to that when we'll get i'm not
i'm i'm i don't claim there's no cash
prizes here heather so we're not giving
away cash oh we're done so i was
promised cash money
i'm done done with this
no it's so we we don't the the prize
here is that um you get to beat gabe at
trivia obviously that's where this is
perfect
because i
because i have a bonus question here on
this one uh because i was actually
interested in
uh i did some more research i did my own
research not on facebook
um but i did did my own research on this
show
and i came up with a bonus question here
bonus question is who made the most
appearances on hollywood squares is it a
whoopi goldberg
is it b jonathan winters
is it c joan rivers
or is it d paul lindy i think it's
whoopee that is not correct gabe do you
want a chance at the yeah yeah yeah is
it paul lindy it is it is paul lindy
gabe is the comeback kid here oh
two to three it was rigged
so so to give you so to give you a
little history here uh lindy appeared
707 times on hollywood squares
yes uh lindy apparently was a very uh
famous uh comedian he wasn't a famous
actor because apparently he was not any
good at acting he was a famous comedian
but he became the s uh
to be known as the center man like this
was his claim to fame
this was his claim to fame to be the
center square on hollywood squares
because he had so many appearances right
that's how i remember him on the show
because he was always on right like he
also has a very
uh unique voice
right like he reminds me of um
uh if you guys ever watched an american
dad he sounds kind of if i remember he
sounds similar to the alien on the show
that was in the attic
anyway
so that's that's where gabe's going is
the aliens in the attic yeah yeah he's
like yeah that's where i got this answer
that's right i got this answer but but
to your your answer heather in 1998
whoopi goldberg did start to pre they
brought the show back because in the
early 90s it went away yeah i remember
whoopi's yeah whoopi's production
company brought it back back and not
only was she the executive producer but
she was the permanent center square
until 2002.
right right so that's why i did throw
that in to trip up but but i mean i
still think it was this was rigged i
don't know collusion
[Music]
[Laughter]
and whoopi whoopi actually left in 2002
and i think uh did you join the viewer
i think so and hillary winkler took over
the show for a few years and i think it
was jeffrey tambor that was the host for
a while of the modern what what what our
generation thinks of as hollywood square
yes
um so but um um no it's uh hollywood
squares has a lot of history if you go
look it up
or either you're interested or not so
question number five final question here
whoever
answers this either is a tie because i
do not have a tiebreaker question is it
tie or
heather can win it
in many of the early game shows the cash
prizes were not very big heather they
were not very big at all
such was the case with this game show
which originally aired from 1956 to 1968
like modern history type stuff right the
celebrity panel
would hear a story about one of the
three contestants
and had to match the story to the right
contestant
what was the name of this show
remember we were talking about this
earlier oh you're gonna give it away
again
number eight
number a number a number and number a
a
to tell the truth
it's the answer b snap judgment
c spill the beans or d
call my bluff i'm just gonna have to
guess ah
a a is correct a is correct heather wins
heather wins what was it i can't even
tell the truth
to tell the truth okay i i was i was
trying to float this i was trying to
float this earlier with the william
abbingdale jr because they i knew i knew
there was a truth in the tongue i was
like two truths and a lie i was like i
don't think that's what i was thinking
too i'm glad honestly i would have got
it wrong if that was the case because i
knew this question was you're welcome
for the layout 1960s
thank thank you for winning the game
heather there is no cash prize but you
did win uh the trivia game
[Music]
much fun thank you for playing well i
finally get a game show i don't get to
play my own game so i'm excited to like
win
so so with with the game show and like
the video that you did that we watched
um the war on christmas do you find it
uh harder and harder to uh make fun of
the right wing you know people after
that
after trump lost they're like well what
are you gonna do now i'm like oh
oh there's plenty of things
unfortunately uh no i don't find it hard
at all
i mean every day there's something i
mean it's up it is i will say not as
grandiose or as well i won't say as
idiotic but you know lauren bober does
exist so
um yeah no there is plenty there is
plenty of content to keep us going yeah
i can see from from from my own personal
standpoint like
the the
creating the satire or parody you know i
had similar conversations with people
like after the election were like well
trump saw you know he's on his way out
you know now now what are you going to
do or or what i really enjoy were the
people that would threaten me or
whatever in comments and be like oh well
he's not present anymore now what you
know and it's like
he's not do you think he's the only
person in politics like i there there is
a whole body of government
beyond him
so
i mean i guess i'm not surprised that
you think it's only donald trump like
you probably do worship this dictator
which i'll probably continue to make fun
of you
type of people
but yeah
which you have done a fantastic job of
by the way
it's i mean it really yeah thank you it
really is one of those things where uh
i'm just like you guys
continue to provide more and more
material and then once i create the
material you are there to provide more
and more
complementary material in the comments
and then i'll make another video or this
or that or what have you but yeah it's
just one of those things where they like
oh what are you gonna do now i'm gonna
do the same thing and he's probably not
gonna leave despite the fact that he was
like if i lose the election you'll never
hear from me again
well unfortunately we still hear from
you every single day why couldn't we is
that another lie why couldn't even just
have like one truth could that not have
been the one for him to just go away
forever
you know speaking of the orange man
there is a book there behind you that i
want to ask you about the mean orange oh
really what else should i just put right
here in the frame for you
oh oh how how funny you should see this
yeah what what is that book it's my
pride and joy um so it's it's so weird
and funny to think about like all the
things that we have done in just a short
amount of time like content wise and how
different my life is doing this kind of
stuff i never in a million years thought
that i could say that we published a
book and here we are this is a parody
book this turned out um it was a tick
tock video that my husband did
we do parodies uh as you saw the parody
song but we did a parody book of the
green eggs and ham and we just he wrote
it wrote a little book i put together
um a video on it it was just our normal
stuff nothing fancy no fancy graphics or
illustrations or anything and we were on
our way to like a socially distance like
barbecue at the time and like posting it
in the car like hit send by the time we
got to the barbecue um which was like an
hour away it was it already had hit like
50 000 views which is wild people like
hundreds thousands of comments where can
we get this book and so we just decided
we're like okay we're gonna do it we're
going to
do this book and so we hired an artist
to
commission you know all of these
illustrations my
personal favorite i mean it's real
trolly on trump you know but also you
know like the factual uh you know we do
not like it when he tweets we do not uh
or when he sends troops to our streets
this was all based on the current stuff
that was happening this was based on the
george floyd's protest in washington you
know we use real real quotes from him
you know obama spy on my campaign the
thugs you know
all kind of stuff but this one's my
favorite
the uh oh we do not like his stance on
guns a good guy with a gun we do not
like his cokehead son
i mean this is a fantastic children's
book
thank you so much um you know people
some people did not agree
so
so so where where do we find this book
this is you know what this was a limited
now now it's rare now it's worth
definitely more than 20
um we sold out
oh fantastic fantastic i know i don't
know right it was crazy we did like a
pre-order to see how many people
actually wanted to buy it and then so we
posted because we did the regular video
then we like and within a month we had
like the we found the publisher we we
had to like um
he's like a register my husband is a
registered author now like if you google
his name he comes up and he's an author
i became a publisher because you have to
have like names wild crazy stuff um and
all this on the ride to a to a barbecue
i know
we just decided we're like we can do
this we could do this um and so we put
out a video after like all the the
graphics came out and it is still our
number one video today we got five
million views that is awesome on this
video and we sold out i see why you're
proud of the book i am it's just like
it's just so like it's nothing i ever
thought that i would do and like same
same with the occupy democrats trivia
show like this is something that i never
thought that i would would do and you
know we teamed up with midas um earlier
this year and produced from this very
same spot our own version of a late
night show you know with my feminist
like you know slant and everything and
like this there's so much that i just
didn't realize that i had in me
or you know working us working together
too we've been together for 11 years and
on the same like path we've been in the
same industry and never once thought to
work together and you know it's just
like why like why limit yourself i we
published a book that's crazy that's
right out of it i am you're a publisher
he's an author and you have figured out
that you can work together without
killing each other
most
[Laughter]
so so there is a new segment that we
want to do here and it's not a trivia
question but it is a question because uh
before we before we shoot to you
giving us your shameless plug of where
we can find all this stuff i want to do
one more thing okay
and the
it's a it's a random card draw and the
one more thing is a question and here's
the question have you ever eaten a whole
tube of pringles by yourself so we want
to have a discussion here of have you so
we want to know the world wants to know
oh do they do they do it
yeah they absolutely do have you ever
sat and ate
you know once you pop you can't stop
right have you ever ate you ever ate a
whole can of pranks probably probably
but truth be told i haven't had pringles
in a very long time but probably because
we used to have them at my house you
know as a kid growing up and it's true
once you pop you cannot stop so probably
yeah
gabe how about you have you ever been
able to sit and eat an entire can of
pringles
uh
i
don't recall if i've ever eaten a whole
can of pringles i've definitely run
through
other bags of chips you know
like what's your favorite i'm a big
kettle uh oh i love those you know so
you know
so yeah yeah like uh
like a sea salt and vinegar or a
jalapeno you know those are pretty good
you see these chip connoisseur things
see i'm like a doritos nacho and cheese
i'm a ruffles man
right right correct ladies i do love
chips yeah well hell yeah they're good i
mean how do you think americans are so
tubby is the is the chip conglomerate is
keeping us fat and that's why that's why
because when i read this question i'm
like oh
man have i went through cans of pringles
yeah happy bamboo tell us
well so there are several
of course the original pringles are the
[ __ ] bomb like that's that's where
it's at right what do you mean the
original pringles like just the original
flavor the salt
i thought you meant like there was an
original like you know how there's like
classic coke with like real sugar and
then there's like the us coke with like
whatever sugar
i thought you were saying like there was
an original recipe
you know originally i mean technically
there is it is that that's how they
started was the one yeah oh one yeah
okay i get it now i i get i get what
you're saying okay but so so so the
original are the [ __ ] bomb
and then of course sour cream and onion
kick so much yes right so good but
what what
yeah the sour cream and onion oh it's
coming from sea salt and vinegar over
here come on
sour cream get out of here
i i don't even i don't even eat sour
cream but i eat sour cream and onion
chips bye guys do you like the sour
cream and what is it cheddar cheese yeah
what is the best that one do i [ __ ]
oh yeah the sour cream and cheddar
cheddar and salad bridges
yeah oh my god and the cheese sticks in
there and you can like you can almost
like lick the cheese and the sour cream
top of it before you eat the chip that's
how good it is yup yup now uh like when
you pull one out of the bag and it's
just cooked in the cheese you're like oh
this is this is what i've been waiting
for this entire bag is this one chip
with all this cheesecake on it is the
one chip i'm winning
no i'm good i'm good yeah just like i'm
you know like i don't like when people
uh that way people i don't like uh
cool ranch uh what yeah yeah i'll give
you that one actually cool ranch is not
my fave
yeah you know i hate when they do like
the the crazy ones like
like buffalo wild wings they do all
kinds of crazy ass flavors now and they
do the kind oh my god yeah yeah what's
wrong
with it was it
was it lays or who was it that was i
think it was lay's it was the you can
you can uh submit your own flavors and
we'll make it
yeah like combine flavors right right
and then they would put on the shelves
and the shelves were the real tests to
be like you know people voted online
they submitted this is what was picked
and then from there like is this going
to be a
a new leader in the chip space right
yeah i would so see more miss
so see heather next time you you launch
a product because you are you are
launching products all over the place
here next time you launch a product you
should you know combine flavors put it
on a shelf
have the consumer go get this product
and vote on boat on rather this which
one they should have perfect i really do
appreciate you joining us today and
thank you for giving us your insight
into the pringles i mean obviously
me and you know what the pringles is and
it's hard to know this stuff but you
need to know education first education
absolutely absolutely thank you guys so
so give us give us a shameless plug of
where we can find not only the trivia
show but we can find all your stuff uh
all those videos that you make tell us
where all this content is where it lives
you can find me
literally anywhere too many social media
sites at
heathergtv or just type in heather
gardner i'm usually one of the first
ones that pop up um but then also the
trivia show which launches on monday i'm
not sure what when this airs but monday
we'll be playing all through this week
monday through friday starting tomorrow
which is december 13th through the 17th
on the occupy democrats facebook page
it's facebook.com occupy democrats and
the cool thing about this show is that
it's going to be live so make sure you
set an alarm you have to play live and
you can interact and play and submit
your answers from everyone across the
united states which is so cool it's so
cool it's the very first social media
game show where people can actually play
together on facebook
it's really really kind of cool so yeah
and it's going to be on four o'clock my
time which is pacific and then 7 00 p.m
eastern time west coast coast west coast
coast oh man you you california people
see here see i tried to give you a
shameless vlog and then you're doing the
soros california thing you're crying out
loud
no i i do i do i i want to thank you for
coming on and please come back anytime
not just to interview but maybe maybe
we'll have you on like uh as a guest
host of our trivia show or something
maybe we have some fun maybe we have
some big guests
and you can come up with the trivia or
something because you are now
you are now the left-wing soros trivia
queen
thank you so i appreciate you coming
thank you i this is a title that i will
take very seriously thank you
i really do i i i'm so glad you came on
and uh
never be shy if you want to come back on
let us know we'll have you on anytime if
there's something you'd like to to uh
especially tell gabe about uh potato
chips and school him i i was about to
say we need to get him up to speed on
these flavors i know i know this is
really oh boy
thank you guys thank you very much
absolutely and stay with us we'll be
right back after these messages thanks
for joining us thank you
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new maga skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
thanks for sticking with us
what a great interview
really really really really great
interview with heather we had fun
playing
trivia
with heather uh and gabe you know that
you didn't win
no but
we did have a lot of fun
yeah it was a ton of fun uh
i'll get her next time
hey well you were close you were you
were about to come back i was i was
coming back
i i know i know well if there was
another question in the mix
oh so you're blaming it on me i don't
know also i'm pretty sure that when you
get the question right the bonus
question is then given to you you know
oh
oh so now i'm being blamed now i'm being
blamed for not not adhering to the rules
correctly it's fine i got the question i
got the bonus question right now got the
question anyway so what what the hell is
all the all the it's about the damn
principle tony oh okay okay okay well
next time next time i host
and don't play
i'll try to remember to make sure to rig
it up so that our guest wins and you
lose again exactly thank you
just admitting the truth so you know
uh i i want to i want to say at the end
there with the chip thing i don't know
if anyone likes the new one more thing
but i really like the one more thing
where we draw a card just some random
ass question and uh i i i had i did not
have you penned in as a salt and vinegar
chip person which is kind of that's the
thing these one more thing these
questions
right you don't know what happened right
right you know yeah
i surprised you maybe i surprised other
people too you know maybe it shouldn't
be such a surprise that you're or i mean
maybe it shouldn't be i mean it is but
maybe it shouldn't be i think they're a
great like you know you you can snack
you know i'll have my like my
you know my sparkling water maybe some
chips you know
like i'll have sparkling water and for
people out there our audience that
doesn't know
this guy is always always trying to push
the sparkling water on me like all the
time i mean we're in production i just
wanna i just wanna have a direct tap i
want a direct co2 line feed me water
i've got my own little [ __ ]
hey look i got my own little soda stream
in my in my in uh in my kitchen
and it's great it saves me tons of money
you know i buy a little we don't get
paid why are you pimping we don't win
i'm hoping that i'm hoping that maybe
sodastream will hear this like somebody
will like and we'll finally get a
sponsor on the show yeah and i would
love to just every day just like sip on
some soda stream water and be like ah
this podcast is even more fresh
because
of you know sodastream water or like i
wasn't as parched anymore and i was able
to talk without cottonmouth thanks to
sodastream crazy maybe we should have
the guy that does our parody commercials
do some kind of uh yeah yeah work up
something on the uh on on sparkling
water yeah exactly so so let me ask is
carbonated water and sparkling water are
the same right
yes but there are differences between uh
here we go
here we go
club soda
uh so you've got club soda tonic which
is sweeter then you've got
there's sparkling water then there's uh
uh there is
um
which any reasonable person knows that
this is all
just just turn the damn faucet on and
get a glass of ice water would you
please yeah but it's like you know let's
say you go work out or you know you're
really parched i mean it has been
science
scientifically proven that carbonated
like
not trying to attract the q anon crowd
i'm just saying
yeah it just it's it satiates the
the thirst quench that you have it's not
gatorade gatorade is not a thirst
cruncher okay it's sparkling butter
we're gonna we're gonna start getting
we're gonna start getting the boneheads
watching our show because gabe is
preaching all this wellness now speaking
of boneheads being opponents we do have
bone end of the week uh let me put up
the contestants now i i did kind of mess
this up this week i don't know if you
know this game but i did mess this up i
put out the poll for the pony of the
week and christian walker lauren
beauberg and mark meadows
uh are on the pole
now you caught it last week and i had to
delete it and redo it
but i i didn't do it for the entire week
but i do feel like
i do feel it
i i knew there would be i knew there
would be something goodbye i'm i'm
leaving
you later
so so but but i i let me let me bring it
up here here's the um let's see here's
is it over did it end it ended wow wow
it ended people can't even vote on it
now listen but listen we got 935 votes
which is fantastic yeah yeah i don't
think here's the thing i i did i did see
it this morning i didn't realize that it
was over
but uh
i feel like mark meadows was a hard one
to beat
i
well you know it was closer than i
imagined it would be actually
like you got 20 20 less than 24 to
christian walker which was if anyone
realizes why we put him on there is
because of this little viral video that
he did where he's standing from a gas
pump complaining about filling up his
land rover where he's got like a a six
thousand dollar hoodie on or some [ __ ]
yeah i think i think it also in the
video he says for his landowner which he
paid 90 anyone who anyone
who
complains about paying for gas for their
suv needs to shut the [ __ ] up right okay
uh you bought an suv you bought
something that is literally the worst
gas mileage in a city just because you
have a little peepee and you have some
sort of like right situation to
compensate for i don't really care but
at the end or you got the money to throw
at it and you can fill up not exactly
right you know mike that's what's and i
actually said this i think on the
shitless roundup uh when when i was
talking about this video i i i said this
guy is n because like when he's like
when he's pointing at the gas pump he
doesn't know which number to point at
because he's not sure which one is the
price which one's the gallon like he's
never probably really ever worried about
the price of gas or he probably ever
pulled up his own car right he's
probably always has someone go fill it
up and bring it back
so like i have a i will say this for
context for anyone listening
christian walker and i we have history
okay i started making these videos
because
he uh
he has a tendency to just
speak
um
just absurdity he has he has a tendency
to just say dumb [ __ ] that he knows
nothing about so i make these little
videos that are uh one is a character
that i'm his roommate and i live with
him i have to deal with this and it's
usually like through a facetime call or
i'm on the other side of the door while
he's ranting or i'm in the back seat of
the car
the other one is when he's in line
at starbucks giving an order and i'm the
starbucks barista having to deal with it
and i'm having a side conversation in
the actual uh
coffee shop
but he found out that i was making these
videos and got very upset at me and was
uh he he should be as he should right
right right well the reason he was so
mad was because i was calling him out on
these things and my videos on tick tock
before he got banned twice
my videos on tick tock were were getting
more views and getting more engagement
because the people who were
he was pissing up were then coming to my
videos
for that
and
uh
what ended up happening is he left the
platform but he before that he blocked
me on twitter and instagram and tick
tock which i found hilarious
specifically because it's coming from
someone who is like
don't censor freedom freedom of speech
right like i've got my first amendment
right don'ts and it's like that that's
all he blabbers on about too well that's
all any of these con conservatives no
one can tell you past the second
amendment what right the bill right i
mean can they really tell you the first
or the second what they actually say
they can't even get those no no no well
they they only can tell you one part of
a longer uh right clause speaking of
people who don't know the first or
second amendment it brings us to our
second contestant here because uh lauren
bobert got uh just under 32 of the vote
of the 935 votes um and of course she
doesn't know anything about the second
amendment either right i mean nope she
she claims she does and she has what
what's what's the [ __ ] name of her
restaurant she she oh it was called uh
is it called like guns or shooters or
some [ __ ] or shooters shooters grill
shooters shooters grill the one where
she serves the diarrhea uh loose meat
sandwiches right right the pork sliders
that's going right through yeah into the
toilet right yeah that's the one where
their weight staff are able to open
carry while serving food because that's
not some sort of like
combination
or a bad outcome
what you mean lauren bobert and cooking
food in general or just her oh yeah no
for that yes for her and that in general
but also these waiters it's like what
happens when it's like i i don't know if
there's ever been a disgruntled uh
like customer before but they can bring
guns in as well so it's like
what's gonna happen here you know i know
well and and you know i can't even
remember why we put her on the uh i will
have to remember this because
it wasn't
go ahead
uh
there's no telling there's so many stuff
because we'll have to we'll have to
recall because we always do the bonehead
of the week show every weekend um so
we'll have to remember for the show
maybe we'll have some video evidence of
why we even put her on the list because
i actually like sitting here i'm not
even recalling exactly the reason why so
we'll have to look that up and
recall and we'll probably have to pull
some video up for for this weekend's
show because you guys know we do the
bone end of the week every weekend um
and we've been i think this is uh we're
on number four right and we're in four
then yeah yeah third or fourth one
before yeah you go to the youtube um
subscribe to the uh youtube channel and
uh you can go over and look at bone end
of the week of course we will do another
episode this weekend oh you know what i
remember now it's because she did that
she had the tweet that was pushing the q
a on conspiracy about missing children
oh yeah yeah that's right that's right
yeah because it was
the previous week she had uh well
uh around thanksgiving she had pushed
the whole ilhan omar is uh the jihad
then she doubled down on it and did her
christmas card giving all her kids um
you know assault
and then
she tripled down
by then pushing more [ __ ]
it's really hard to keep track of this
this this crazy ass though
well and we all know why mark we all
know why
mark meadows is on there and i guess i
guess maybe by the weekend by the time
we get to the bone of the week show
we'll probably have some more mark metal
news and what i mean by that is maybe
we'll have lauren bobert and mark meadow
news because by then maybe we'll have
some more of these uh it's crazy it's
crazy to actually see these texts
um
and know who they're from but i think
the january 6 select committee like by
putting out these lawmaker tw like it's
almost like they're [ __ ] toying with
them right like well maybe they are
though
yeah so i don't i forgot if we were
talking to someone or if we were just
like
someone that we were exchanging with on
on twitter but
someone was um
talking about how it's a slow burn right
so like
releasing these things one at a time now
they very well may be getting this
information like slowly as they're like
you know requesting data from companies
or from people
but also they might be planning this out
to be like okay on this day we're gonna
drop these texts we're gonna drop this
communication we're going to drop this
subpoena and this and this and this and
this because if you did it all once
right it all kind of
gets overwhelming and people might lose
track of something
but you've got a constant burn on
something that's happening you might
have a better chance of
you know instead of throwing like one
big
rock into the the body of water you're
dropping a little bunch of smaller rocks
right right
because i've been saying that for a long
time is it's kind of this little drip
drip drip because they don't want to
release everything at once because the
trump chaos machine like you said would
just take over these things and devour
the important parts because the other
text that i can't wait to see
it because they even alluded to it in
the contempt hearing is that um there's
a lot of staffers that have already come
forward which that means that there's
probably message between not only the
congress person who is who is texting
with mark meadows
and trying to coordinate with the white
house um and maybe even some of the
writers themselves but that the staff
members and the congress person as well
like what is that communication like
what are they saying amongst themselves
meaning like getting to the intent and
the thought and the mythology of you
know a
methodology excuse me of what they're
trying to actually accomplish with the
cheeto dust kangaroo like i think that's
gonna be uh some earth-shattering stuff
and they've already said that they've
got hundreds
uh possibly of
current congress people and even staff
members that are coming forward
i think if there's anything like we've
we already knew republicans like in some
ways republicans are really smart in how
they
strategize certain policies and [ __ ]
over other people however
other times they can be really [ __ ]
dumb
and i say that because they're over here
sending texts
uh you know it's revealed they're buying
burner phones they made a powerpoint
presentation on how to do one two three
and i'm like
if they're
in the committee hearing that he was
using a personal email which remember
that was the earth shattering thing that
you're not supposed to do and and i mean
that was disqualifying to bleed the
country or some dumpster exactly yeah i
mean the same stuff happened with ivanka
and jared they were using personal
communications and public platforms and
no one was like everyone's like oh well
that's you know that's that's different
different it's like that's not different
but yeah okay
but i will say um
for all these communications
and plans that they made like if they
were that dumb
to do those things
uh
then they most definitely have personal
communications with all these staffers
and other people like nobody's if they
just bought a day or two before three
burner phones for
uh
uh what's her face and her mom and
someone else
meanwhile in communication with lara
trump eric trump mark meadows and other
people higher up i'm going to safely
assume
that they were not careful about keeping
all of their communications um
in private like this stuff is going to
be publicly someone's going to like text
something and they're going to oh
there's going
have you well have you seen the story
about the bonnie and clyde
insurrectionist have you seen this story
i was just looking at the story about
them yes so they're gonna they're gonna
go deep be deposed by the june they've
already turned over bunch documents
because they're disgruntled because they
were supposed to get pardons from
something that happened back in 2020
with this steve bannon build a wall
thing and they never received a pardon
so uh and which there possibly
communication with a congressman maybe
with trump that's saying yeah i'll
pardon you or whatever if you help me
plan this you know who knows what's
going to come out of that even so yeah i
think i think um making sure that people
know that the january 6 select committee
is not [ __ ] around this idea
you know because i'm really sick of
hearing this [ __ ] that that all they're
not going to do anything department
justice no yeah it's all [ __ ]
and it's obvious now that that was all
[ __ ] the entire time that peddling
this conspiracy theory that somehow
merrick garland the department of
justice in this january 6 select
committee is on trump's side and it's
all there to make sure trump then yeah
give me a [ __ ] break so so that that
kind of dampened that um when members of
congress are freaking out and we know
who they are because they're freaking
out and there's a list of them that have
already had their [ __ ] social media
subpoenaed and stuff speaking of social
media don't forget to go like and follow
and subscribe on our channels mine and
gabe's both at the tony michaels at i am
gabe sanchez as well twitter instagram
the tiki talks
uh and check out all and go to uh go to
the the twitter page of the podcast at
tonymichaelspod follow us there that's
where you will find this bonehead of the
week
uh uh poll every single week and
hopefully whoever does the poll doesn't
screw it up like they did this week yeah
well you know it happens it happens and
we we got a thousand votes and like i
think yeah end up setting for like two
days so that's pretty good keep voting
out there because we we love the bone
end of the week we like to do the show
yeah um i know you guys like it you guys
like the little video
that gabe does of the heads moving side
with their little music and the pop at
the end that's and that's that's always
fun that's always right now we know
unfortunately or fortunately we know who
the winner is you can go ahead and make
the little
you go ahead and make a little video go
ahead and make the video now you make
the video you make the video and stay
tuned to the [ __ ] list roundup again
that is everyday twitter twitch uh noon
eastern 11 central and then come visit
us on the weekends for the bonehead of
the week and next week uh we already
have a guest planned to record i'm not
going to give it away now because we
haven't recorded it yet but stay tuned
next week we have a guest we're going to
play trivia just like every week two
hours every single week of let's talk
nintendo michael's podcast gabe
thanks for joining us thanks for uh all
the work today because we were we were
getting in on the uh you know yeah
people don't know the background the
11th house right in right we were right
there at the very end
so thanks for joining us
come back next week
thank you to all of you see you later
gabe
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking